beaucoup de choses se sont passées
depuis mon grand mariage grec
[Musique]
mon père nous a quitté et sa dernière
volonté était que nous visions sont
villages d'enfance pour renouer avec nos
origines donc on va tous se réunir on
s'en va en Grèce oh ouais
et quand je dis oh je vais dire toute la
famille
y a-t-il quelqu'un du nom de souvlaki
sur ce vol
Aristote je savais pas que tu serais là
j'étais comme une vieille chaussette
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes la famille pour ton calotte on
a des liens familiaux via le Papou de
votre papa qui était marié à la sœur de
la belle-sœur de mon arrière
et je serai ta préférée
j'ai promis à mon père que je trouverai
ses meilleurs amis je les connais très
bien arrivés encore ici non alors où
est-ce qu'ils sont ils vont venir pour
la réunion de famille ils t'ont dit
qu'il viendrait non
alors il y a pas d'autre chose on va
dormir en famille voilà des
retrouvailles
on n'est pas prêt d'oublier
connaissez-vous ces hommes non je suis
surprise mais je ne suis pas surprise
parce que je ne suis jamais surprises
j'ai rien compris
[Musique]
il faut vraiment que je trouve les amis
de mon père on s'en occupe Angelo et moi
ok salut
[Musique]
c'est parti
c'est décidé comme c'est toi qui nous a
ramené en Grèce
c'est toi la chef de famille maintenant
lequel vous voulez qu'on mange ce soir
c'est gentil je suis végétarien
non
[Musique]